most people most Champions do not have
something that you do not have they lack
something that you have for a champion
in the Physical Realm a lot of times
it's they don't have an off switch they
just keep going and so to the same
degree you probably do things every
single day that you should not be doing
and so what I want to introduce to you
is a concept of the anti-routine as the
most productive routine that is humanly
possible for you to accomplish what you
want number one is obviously just
shifting the perspective of I need to do
more things and I need to add more
things to my routine when in fact you
need to stop doing things that you're
currently doing all that remains is the
work to be done priorities mean two
things cannot be equally important when
you work on something if I spend 30
minutes on both things and I say this
one's more important than this one I can
say that but that's not reality because
I basically just said they were both
important which means neither of them
are which is why most people cannot get
done because they cannot say no you need
to have a routine of saying no an
anti-routine and that is the thing
that's going to yield those outsize
Returns on productivity you can't do two
things with different levels of
importance it's either important or it's
not important so if you say this is the
priority then it means you do not do
other things besides that thing that is
how it is a priority that is how you
literally prioritize need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Alex hermosi and my take on
his top 10 worlds of success enjoy
rule number two set your own rules we
think that for some reason we are doing
something wrong when we are not
self-caring because it is bad too not
self-care because we should we must or
else or what and the reason this pisses
me off the reason that I made a tweet
that went viral um this morning about
this is that weekends are new for humans
they're not even 100 years old 1929 in
England is when the first weekend got
passed by a union and it's because
people hated what they were doing for
their life and so if you want to truly
give self-care then stop hating what you
do every day novel concept I know stop
hanging out with people that suck
mind-blowing like I said I know and the
reason that I am so passionate about
this is that I have been told throughout
my entire life that I was working too
much I was not balancing the things that
I was supposed to be balancing and you
know what who gives it's my life I don't
need to live by anyone else's rules and
neither do you right and so when people
say you should be doing this you are not
doing X XYZ just take a pause and be
like are these rules that I want to
listen to are those your rules that
you're trying to apply to my life
because there are no rules you can do
whatever the hell you want if you want
to work for a year straight work for a
year straight and the reason you can
work for a year straight is because you
like what you do the reason these people
try and project their own self-hatred
for their own lives onto you is because
they cannot imagine a world in which
someone might actually like what they do
every day and didn't don't need an
escape a break from what their existence
is on a daily basis and so don't feel
guilty for just being you and if you
don't like your life every day rather
than try and figure out and make time
for self-care it would probably be
better to flip the ratio and start
thinking what can I do in my actual life
to stop hating it so much that I need an
escape from it right and that's
different from like yes you need to
sleep yes you need to you know rest Etc
but there's a difference between that
and like I just need a total spa day and
if that's how you relax cool but the
thing is is projecting on someone else
how they should Moss need to have to
relax or do whatever it's nonsensical it
doesn't exist right I wanted to make
this video even though it's short
because I it just drives me bananas if
you want to work work if you want to
take off take off just don't listen to
what anyone else says about what you
should do for your life you're going to
die and so will they and it's not going
to matter and in 10 Generations don't
even remember your name so do what you
want you're going to die and that is the
ultimate freedom and for some reason we
live under these chains that we think
exists but don't and so I think the
process of of growing and really making
ourselves free is just simply
identifying the things that don't really
exist and only existed in our mind to
begin with and I think that's why
self-creator really bugs the [__] out of
me or this whole self-care movement it's
also softest like just work right to get
it done you need to like give yourself a
bubble bath every day because like your
work's so hard like humans been here a
very long time we've dealt with much
much harder your you know boss having a
deadline the next day is not the worst
that you've been through and so as a
final sign off on this think about the
hardest things that you have been
through through in your life everyone
has gone through hardship everyone has
had difficulties in childhood everyone
has had difficulties with siblings with
parents blah blah blah blah these events
that shape Our Lives you have been
through harder than this you will
survive it will be okay you don't need
to self-care you don't need to listen to
what anyone else is saying you do you
and if that means self-care by all means
but just don't protect anyone else rule
number three Find meaning I would say
there are days that I feel like less
energized or things like that for sure
are not about like the big picture of
like I don't believe that this cause is
not worthy but I do think a lot of
people have that too where they're like
what I'm doing is meaningless right and
then I get into I think everything's
meaningless and then we can just create
whatever meaning you know we choose to
because if we don't believe in a capital
M meeting which a lot of people disagree
with that's fine but if you don't
believe in a capital N meaning I think
that's very freeing because then you can
create Little M meaning for whatever you
want and so if you believe you can then
choose to architect your own life in
whatever ways that you deem meaningful
and make the activities you do aligned
with that meeting the difference between
capital M meaning and Little M meaning
and this is kind of like the basis of
nihilism which people have like a very
negative Viewpoint around which I'm not
entirely sure about why but like Capital
meeting means that like this is the
meaning of life period like for everyone
this is the meaning of life whereas if
we say that there is no single agreed
upon meaning of life and then people say
well then that is your big meaning of
life and I'm like yes you're right I
believe that there is no meaning that is
the meaning that I that I believe and
they're like well then that is the
capital then sure that's my capital A
meaning is that there is no meaning
what's the implication of that it means
now that we have meaning making machines
in our brain and so we get to create and
Destroy meaning as we see fat and so if
we choose an activity and we deem that
goal meaningful because we think it's
more interesting or it energizes us then
we can ascribe meaning to that and do
more of it and what's nice about not
having capital M meaning is that that
can shift right that might be good for a
season and then it can shift I will say
that the downside of not having capital
M meaning which I consider to be
religion off the shelf is that it's more
difficult because you have no one who's
saying here's the big box of rules you
can read it and then that way you don't
have to make the decisions about it but
I think it's more difficult but in
ultimately more rewarding if you have
reasoning behind why you believe what
you believe because then you have to
independently come up with your own
conclusions about those things it also
makes it malleable so that if you get
new data or new evidence then you can
change your mind which a lot of people
again have difficulty with but like if
you change the information then it would
make sense that if it materially changes
the outcome that the way that you
believe about something should change
and I think a lot of people will
identify with their beliefs as a part of
themselves rather than as what I prefer
to call them which is assumptions
because they work the same way what's
the difference in belief and assumption
not a lot right the only difference is
just what we call the word and so
assumptions are based on things that
we've observed and then we assume
something as a result and so I would say
that beliefs are just assumptions and
but when you call them that they become
less tied to your identity if you have
an assumption you don't say you
challenged my assumption it's like well
yeah it challenged my assumption Ah
that's great I I was assuming this it
must be this and then they become much
more flexible and then we don't tie our
egos into them and I think ultimately it
serves more people better in the long
run rule number four outwork yourself
I've said this quote many times in our
communities and on this channel which is
you must outwork yourself down right if
you feel like you are not confident then
you must outwork the things that you're
insecure about if you're like man I'm
selling these services and I'm not sure
I'm not sure if I'm that good at them
then do more of them and don't pretend
honesty is one of the most compelling
and convicting things for persuading
people right saying what you are good at
and what you are not good at truthfully
will we knew far more followers and fans
and and loyal customers and loyal
employees than pretending because the
end of the day they can feel that you
are disingenuous because they know that
is hollow they know that on the inside
you do not believe the words that are
coming out of your mouth and that is how
people speak without conviction and they
cannot sway others because they have not
swayed themselves because they have lost
their own respect and so I am not the
believer in buying the Ferrari when you
can't afford it I am not the believer in
in affording the home and paying for the
home
that you cannot afford because you want
to pretend like this is the lifestyle
that you want to be around if you go
into the guise of networking you can
still go to those places without buying
a four million dollar house when you
you're barely making you know a few
hundred thousand dollars a year it
doesn't make sense I like Jay-Z's quote
around this which is if you can't buy
something twice don't buy it once I
really like that and so
this is one of the most common questions
I get for newer entrepreneurs because
they think that they have to they have
to they have to pose on Instagram in
order to get to to get wealthy and what
it does is it conflates sequence Jeff
Bezos is famous because of what he did
not because he became famous as Jeff
Bezos and then used his following to
build something Elon Musk is famous for
what he's accomplished not for being
Elon Musk and then creating something as
a result right let the actions be the
thing that gives you the fame rather
than yourself right at least that is
that is Alex's two cents in my viewpoint
in the world and I think most of nosy
Nation you guys uh share that belief
with me and for those of you who are new
to this channel you're going to get more
of this type of stuff uh and none of the
fake until you make it nonsense that is
a sure way uh to be broke and I will
tell you this as a last thing
the amount of people who in 2008 when
everything crashed who were faking it
until they quote made it
just faked it until they lost it all
because they lost what little amount
that they had because they were so
overextended but I can tell you that
just about everyone can become wealthy
if you choose to live on Lower unless
than you make right and that is a ratio
wealth is a ratio not a number all right
and so anywho if you are having
struggles with this question I would
pause it I would I would beg of you that
you build your own respect first that
you're honest with yourself first and if
you always maintain the Integrity of hey
last year we we got smashed right this
year we'll do a little bit better and
two years from now when you do even
better than that you can be truthful and
people will believe you but if you
always are telling a story about how
you're always doing so well hey everyone
will hate you B no one cares and C you
will know that you are full of it and at
the end of the day I think that is the
only thing that we're going to keep with
us and when we die once everyone's going
to forget about us anyways so you might
as well at least enjoy yourself while
you're alive also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five develop good
relationships we have these people that
we collect you know throughout our lives
and sometimes they come in you know you
probably heard the saying they're here
for a season or reason or a lifetime and
I think you know for me a lot of people
have been seasonal and so I wanted to
share that because I know that I mean
I'm sure some of you have had a similar
path to me in that I didn't have a
tremendous amount of support from my
parents I think they now retroactively
think they supported me because it's
much easier that way but I did not I did
not have any support from my parents for
the decisions that I took until it was
already Beyond obvious that I was going
to be successful and that took years and
that was very hard for me at the time I
think friends fell in that same category
and so when I was having this discussion
with Dean we we dove into this a little
bit more but as we you know Ascend
towards our goals and I don't say Ascend
in a literal sense in terms of like
socioeconomic status or whatever but
just like we move closer towards we want
to where we want to go and our vision
and our mission in our lives become
clear it also becomes clear when you
have contrast with people from your past
and I have several rules of thumb that
are I begin to develop around these
relationships one of them is if I could
only talk about the past with someone
they usually aren't good friends of mine
because I don't really live in the past
I live in the future I live in where I
want to go what I want to do the things
that I find interesting where or the
present of the things that I find
interesting today or right now top of
mind and if I can't talk about those
things with somebody then our friendship
kind of by its very nature will decline
over time because there is no growth
right because it's only in the past and
I have felt a tremendous amount of guilt
around the loss of those relationships
but I also felt a guilt of carrying them
on as in I felt like I needed to water
these plants out of necessity rather
than out of you know some sort of
exchange now some people might decry
that or speak against the idea of having
an exchange but I don't think that's
realistic I think that people stay in
relationships because there is an
exchange of value that occurs now I
think the difference is the strength or
depth of the relationship is how long
you are willing to wait for the exchange
to occur so a parent for example is
willing to wait a very long time for a
positive exchange from a child coming
back to them right now and some people
could make the argument that you know
children are a gift throughout the
entire period of time and that's awesome
and that's a perspective whatever but
just to use the time frame as a nice
thinking process if you just met someone
if you don't feel like there's you know
a huge benefit to to to knowing them uh
you know within the immediate future you
probably don't really pursue them out
and the longer you have had positive
exchanges the longer you are willing to
wait for the next one right it's it's
intermittent reinforcement from a
Behavior Uh standpoint right like we are
literally reinforced in this
relationship and the way that addiction
works is the same thing right like you
immediately get Positive Hits and then
you can start extending how long before
you get another positive hit which is
also how abusive relationships work
right like abuse abuse positive abuse
positive positive positive and then like
abuse and then positives a little bit
later and then a little bit later until
the point where there's almost no
positive whatsoever I'm not saying
that's how you should run relationships
but more so how we work as humans the
point of me breaking this down is that I
have lost a lot of the friends or almost
all of the friends that I had uh when I
started my journey and the upside is
people will come into your life to fill
the vacuum that the other people left
but sometimes it doesn't happen
immediately and I think getting
comfortable with having space is a good
thing and a lot lot of people have the
impulse or urge to always have people
around them and I think it's to their
own detriment because I think if you can
spend time alone with your thoughts and
be okay with just being you without
other people then you are more selective
and it's the same way with dating some
people can't be alone some people can't
be without a significant other and so
they just end up shacking up with the
first person they see after they become
single again right and it's because they
have a fear of being alone more than
they hold a they have an aligned Mission
with someone that they think that this
person is really the best pick and so a
lot of ways are similar to dating with
friends in that we can hold out and
really just pick the best people and I
think that you know if we at least for
me if I have two or three good friends
I'm I'm more than satisfied my cup is
very full but I think where I feel
drained is more I feel like I have lots
and lots and lots of acquaintances that
are transactional in nature but purely
transactional or at least they have a
much shorter time Horizon for the
transactions to occur and so I sell this
to say if you have lost friends during
the process of the climb I don't think
it is something that you should lament
or be upset about I think that it is a
sign of growth because a lot of people
say hey you've changed and the only
natural response that I can have to that
is
you have it and I think that that's kind
of sums up the entirety of this of this
video which is if you grow you change
some people most people don't like
change especially if they themselves
have not grown or changed and or if they
have grown in a different direction from
you and it is natural for us to not want
to continue relationships with people
that have grown or have values that are
too far in contrast to our own and those
contract those values can change over
time rule number six do things your way
I feel passionately about my viewpoint
of the world mostly because I struggled
and I was in so much pain for such a
long period of time I'm only sharing
this despite the fact that I get
attacked for sharing this because there
are people who this does resonate with
but when there is no required meaning
then a lot of language changes which is
should must need have to like all of
these things no longer exist because
there is no capital M meaning so I don't
should have to must need to anything and
and so a lot of the expectations that we
bury ourselves into that weigh us down
are just implied shoulds have to's musts
and so if all of those disappeared then
in a lot of ways it's very liberating
and so for me in business it allows me
to take actions even though I know that
I shouldn't or must not or other people
would judge me for not doing it the way
that they thought I should do it because
there are no rules which is why that was
the preface to the book it's like there
are no rules we can live our life
whatever way we want to live it
and that's okay
I read a YouTube comment the other day
it's like hey you know you talk a lot
about being sad and like how have you
been able to X Y and Z and I don't
identify with being a sad person I think
I I have been sad in the past but I also
don't think that there's a problem with
being sad
and so
I think that there's just so much power
and acceptance It's like so many people
make themselves miserable because they
think that they shouldn't be who they
are and they shouldn't feel how they
feel and so much of the medication that
gets prescribed right now is because
someone's like oh I'm anxious and why do
we feel like someone shouldn't be
anxious they are human why do we feel
like we shouldn't feel sad we are human
why do we feel like we shouldn't feel
frustrated or angry we are human and so
I think it's one of the most like
interesting things or phenomena where if
you have a line which is the normal
human existence and you have points
above the line and the points below the
line you have the median right or the
the middle point and people want to not
feel the things below the line and then
we ascribe or label the things below the
line is bad and things above the line is
good when all of it is and so I think
that if we just accept that and accept
ourselves and accept the feelings that
we experience as things that we
experience like rain and weather and
sunshine it's not like rain is bad not
like Sunshine's good it just is I like
happiness is good or happiness is bad or
sadness is bad or sadness is good we
just label it that way and I think the
labels create more suffering than
anything that we ever experience rule
number seven have humility the number
one thing I've struggled with my entire
life is ego
and it's a topic that I don't know I
feel like it gets talked a lot more in
the woo-woo world than it does in like
the entrepreneurial world but you know I
think like ego kills prophets ego Pride
kills profits that's a that's a much
more quotable uh thing uh so pride pride
kills profits and a lot of it is because
like we care more about being right than
serving the other person and there's
this quote about humility that um shoot
I can't remember the guy's name but
um he's the guy who wrote uh I think
disruptive innovation he was a Harvard
Business School Professor I think his
first name is Christian anyways very
very smart guy and he said humility is
not thinking less of oneself but
increasing your regard for others
and that was a really useful definition
for me because it's you know it's not
about pushing yourself down it's about
raising everyone else up and I think
that
um there has been some podcasts that
have gone really well like there's a
school of greatness podcast with Lewis
house that I think is really really good
that's going to come out soon
um there's a podcast
the ice coffee Hour podcast with graham
Stefan uh and Jack Selby on their
channel uh which you can check out is I
think a really good podcast at least
I've gotten a lot of positive feedback
from it
and I was trying to look at like what's
the difference between those ones and
the ones that I come off
you know douchier and you know I'm
partially exploring this out loud with
you guys because like I don't know if
there's times where you're you know not
coming off the way you want to or you're
like not in the right mood or you're
just you're not the best version of you
you know what I mean and I I'm kind of
making this because
I think you know I I feel like just from
the comments and the posts and the tags
and things like that like music nation
and I love you guys to death I think
there are some times where you put me on
a pedestal like I
I am I am something that I am not you
know what I mean like I am very flawed
um and I and I work at it you know what
I mean um and I fail a lot
and ego has been one that I have
struggled a lot with and it was the
thing that really isolated me you know
when I was younger uh because I
definitely you know and I think ego is
another way of saying insecurity
um of just you know wanting to prove
that you're better than people because
deep down you don't feel like you're
good enough and so
for me uh that's been a struggle uh my
entire life and it's been just a I see
it much more as a war than I do a a
battle you know what I mean so you know
Wars have many many battles in them and
at this point I'm definitely not
undefeated so it's much more about like
I'd like to have more W's than L's uh in
the in the wins and losses column around
this and I think I've just had a lot of
L's lately and so
I'll just explain to you what I think
you know my process of what I'm going to
try and think of around this you know in
the future is that um I'm going to try
and
level set before I get on interviews and
so I put a little checklist in my phone
of like hey humility is increasing your
regard for others it's caring more about
the audience it's caring more about the
other person than being right
um and uh and it's it's it's ideally
just lifting up everyone around you and
it's just you know I think there's just
this part of me that always screams out
and wants to you know prove something
and I'm sure that you know a lot of the
material success has come from this
place and I don't think it's a positive
place I think it's a negative one
um
or rather it's a you know an emotion
that that I wouldn't say is a pool it's
a when I see positive negative I should
redefine it as it is an away from fuel
rather than a towards fuel like most of
my motivation has been trying not to
feel like a failure
um in my own eyes
um than it is to you know pull towards
something I'd like to when I operated my
best self I think I have more pool
motivation but I still think that
there's a significant part of me that is
driven away from things and driven away
from Pain rule number eight live in the
moment I love the saying you know in our
20s we're concerned about what everyone
thinks about us in our 40s we don't care
what anyone thinks about us and in our
60s we realize that no one was thinking
about us to begin with right and I just
I just feel like that's I mean who else
have you thought about today besides
yourself probably not I mean you have
your kids which is an extension of
yourself but you know what I mean like
yeah not a lot and so most people are
like that and you know
a lot of it like we have a lot more
leeway than I think we give ourselves
credit for and I think the more that I
have now you know I'll say accomplished
with quotes in in material success the
more I am excited about the things that
I can do and that was why the opening of
the book was like there are no rules and
it just took me a very long time to
realize that and I continue to unlearn
rules that I thought existed you know as
I continue to you know go on this
journey yeah I love that idea of
unlearning I think we all just try to go
back to being like we were when we were
children just because when you're a
child you're purely present you're just
present in the moment and I I don't like
the word happy very much I prefer using
Joy because you can be you can mourn
joyfully
right because it's it's a it's a it's
internal rather than happiness which I
feel is more like happenstance it's more
from external and so um you know one of
the things that bring me joy were things
that I find you know find joy in
um and I think for anyone who's who's
listening it's a much harder question to
answer what are the things that bring me
joy than answering the question what are
the things I hate
and it's easier to correct those first
they're like well I hate my job and I
hate my relationship and I hate the city
okay those are all very changeable and a
lot of times you get there by by
inversion well if I wanted to destroy my
life I wanted to have the worst life
possible what would I do and then taking
all those things that you would do to
really destroy your life and make your
life miserable and then reverse them
it's a much easier way to solve the
positive psychology equation in my
opinion rule number nine manage your
feelings I actually don't think about it
much I think a lot of people spend a lot
of time and effort trying to figure out
how they feel because they want to then
judge or label themselves as I'm doing
well or not well like a lot of effort
goes into something like how do I feel
about this I mean my follow-up question
be like why do you care why does it
matter and that's why when you ask way
long ago about like how much do you
think feelings matter I don't think they
matter at all
like what would the case for feelings
mattering be then why do you believe
they exist it's a good question and it
gets really interesting because it's
like how I experience a feeling that I
label in my head as sadness is it the
same way you experience the thing that
you let it's like seeing green and I see
green and you see green what if all of
our greens are different right I mean
it's it gets very interesting like that
but I think that I experienced something
and if we were to just measure it based
on like brain activity and like heart
rate I would say that I become aroused
in the literal sense uh from
experiencing what I would deem as
emotions and so if we were to describe
it or Define the term in that way I
think I experience emotions and so I
mean I'm fairly confident I experience
emotions if we were to try and measure
it that way then that's how I would say
yes I do experience them but the
question is just like how important are
they and then it would be like for what
if it's for accomplishment not very
important for Fitness not very important
you know if if we're saying how
important is emotion for love which is
another emotion right it becomes like
amorphous trying to go to amorphous but
then you say okay well for defining Love
by AI what I'm willing to endure to
continue to keep something then how
important is it well it depends on how
much I've conditioned myself to accept
this thing so like if I want to stay
married it's probably far more effective
to condition someone to stay married
because that is the external consequence
of a good marriage as you stay together
right I'm just saying like we're just
purely measuring from out from external
circumstances and so I think trying to
measure and Define things is what I
actually geek out on and I really enjoy
I think most people get bored to tears
when I talk about this stuff so I don't
talk about it much but that's the stuff
that like um when when we keep peeling
back layers of like why do you think
you're able to get out of you know a
difficult place in your life or why do
you think you're able to go through
these things a lot of it is because I
believe that I will redefine terms and
so we'll have some instance or something
that I should do and I will redefine it
or I'll say I I don't should I can just
accept it and that's why the biggest
refrain that I have in my head for like
my own mental illness is just like and
that's okay period
like I don't want to go to that thing
that's okay item number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
accept your mortality mortality has been
the single biggest driver and the
biggest decisions that I've made in my
life and it has become a more routine
process for decision making for me in
general uh because I think it it
provides Clarity and it provides context
to most of the decisions we have which
the vast majority of them don't matter
which is helpful in and of themselves
and then you know beyond that it helps
me make the decisions that I think
removes everyone else from The Playbook
because if you if you study subjective
well-being and how people perceive how
they're doing in their own lives it
looks like a smiley face so
seven-year-olds think they're killing
life and then it drops dramatically
between 20 and 30. and then there's
still a little bit more of a dip right
around 45 that's like when people are
their truth they hate life the most and
then and then it kind of slowly goes up
to like 55.60 and then it shoots right
back up again when people see that
they're going to die and that life is
short and that they can make the
decisions without worrying about the
ramifications of other people and some
of the people they're worried about are
also dead and so it was using that
context for that biggest decision that's
been duplicated many times in my life
since then because if I have a good
decision making algorithm I try and
reuse it as many times as I can
most business strategies are not
complicated find something that
something find something people want
charge a lot of money for it and deliver
that thing really well so much so that
they tell other people about your
product it's not overwhelmingly complex
to consider the execution is difficult
but the concept is not and so a lot of
people think they're going to win on
strategy when they're starting a
business when you could have two people
who have lawn care companies and one
person has a long-care company worth a
billion dollars one person that can
barely break five thousand dollars a
month it's not because the strategy is
significantly different it's just the
execution how is it that an entrepreneur
or two entrepreneurs can start at the
exact same time and one can get 10 20 30
times faster or when you start over
again you can always skip these steps to
get to your level of incompetence my
theory around this comes down to pattern
recognition and let me explain it's not
just pattern recognition from the
perspective that you have strategies are
something that you're you're recognizing
but actually patterns in people and so
I'm going to give this a quick story to
drive this this point home I have
struggled for the last decade to find an
assistant and so it's one of the things
I'm actually you know a little
embarrassed about but I I've gone over
seven on assistance
um so much sort of the point that I was
just I almost kind of gave up just even
trying to find an assistant and until
recently I every time I had an assistant
it just always right off the bat it just
never felt like right and I always was
like yeah maybe it'll get better it'll
get better at it and they just never
really did and the problem was that I
didn't know what it looks like when it's
right and so in the videos that I talk
about I use the word the term ideal
scene I don't know what the ideal scene
of this Dynamic looks like when we are
scaling companies right and I'll tell
you what I found out there in a second
but like when we're scaling companies
what we have to do is pay down ignorance
tax of knowing what ideal scene looks
like which is where speed comes from
having people who have outside eyes look
in who already do know what I still
ideal scene looks like so you can skip
steps faster and so I'll give you an
example what this looks like in real
life like for me in the role of
executive assistant thank God that like
for me it wasn't a necessary thing to
continue to grow the businesses now that
I have one I don't ever really want to
live life without one but
the entire time I kept bringing people
in I didn't know what to look for we do
hiring you know we do the hiring process
we do an onboarding and training process
they never really got up to speed or we
never really got in sync and then I'd
slowly kind of Fall Away there would be
distance and then it became kind of
awkward and then I would end up having
to cut the relationship and so in this
instance we immediately synced up I
really like the person I trust the
person and they are so proactive in all
aspects of my life that I just sit down
and start working and then she places
things in front of me I'm like hey I got
13 minutes she's like cool do this I'm
like I've got you know 18 minutes here
she's like cool do this and do this and
every time I'm done I'm like hey what
else should I do she's like boom and so
we meet based on the priorities that I
have and then she has this big stack and
knows how long every every one of these
things takes because I talked to her
about how long I think the task will
take and then as I have openings we slot
it in so it's like I wake up and I'm
just crushing work until the end of the
day because I know that the amount of
time that's been allotted for each the
task is the appropriate amount of time
and so and if I do finish early I get
another task done right and so we can we
can we can Crush stuff you need someone
who you can trust like if you're giving
someone your money like or you're trying
to take someone's advice or counsel you
need to trust their intentions all right
and so it's not just whether they have
integrity it's whether they have your
best interest in mind all right so I'm
going to get to how I solve for that in
a second but that is the first character
trait of you need that you need of a
council of somebody of any kind of
council really whether it's investment
law Etc the second is efficacy or their
skill set right so let's think of both
let's think of just different scenarios
here so let's say you might trust your
mom implicitly but she doesn't have the
skill of knowing much about you know how
to structure insurance policies or
trusts or you know investments in Tech
startups right you might not have that
skill but you might trust her intention
right for you specifically on the
reverse of that you might see that
there's this person who's got lots of
skill is prodigious in this but it also
means that they know exactly how to
screw you if they want to right which is
one of the double-sided things of being
really good at something right you know
all the details you know how to write
the agreement structure the deals in
order to make sure that you you know get
the best outcome right and so the idea
is to find someone who has both your
best interest at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
and so you're like well yeah maybe that
seems obvious for me just even boiling
it down to that was very helpful for me
because when I look and I look through
advisors look for people I want to get
counselor from I have to look at these
two things all right so here here's how
I test for the Integrity piece and
here's how you can kind of like you can
control for risk here right one is I
always try and interview as many
advisors as humanly possible all right
and I do that because I'm going to get
as much information from each of the
council during this process that will
give me perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about Julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks this 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your Macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well I guess this is it right I guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgment yet and so the first step in
this is that I interview as many as I
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where I reach out to my network
I make posts Etc to try and get as many
referrals as I can alright so that's
step one step two for the Integrity
piece is that I try and have a line
incentives now a lot of times there are
incentive systems that appear aligned
but not are not in reality so let me
give you an example so in the real
estate market if you're a realtor for
example you may think oh this realtor
has my best interest at heart right
because they have an incentive to sell
the house and so that is why they're
going to get compensated so they want to
sell it for as much as possible ah but
they aren't incentivized to sell for as
much as possible they're incentivized to
sell it as fast as possible and get a
deal closed all right and so think about
this for you selling a house for 500 000
that's worth five hundred thousand
dollars is a normal you know that like
that's normal that's the market price
right but for you to make an extra let's
say twenty five thousand or fifty
thousand dollars would be really
material that would be a huge extra
outcome for you you would probably push
a lot harder to get the extra 25 or 50
000 now let's say that um you could
probably sell it in a day at 450 000
because it's below the market value of
the house right now here's what's crazy
is that if a a selling realtor you know
like total it might be seven percent two
percent goes to the buyer and five
percent goes to the seller if five
percent is going to your realtor five
percent of five hundred thousand dollars
right is 25 Grand okay and so for them
the the fifty thousand dollar decrease
to drop you from 500 to 450 means that
they're going to give up 2500 so they're
gonna make twenty two thousand five
hundred so let me ask you a question now
in the reverse if they sell for 525
they're going to get 27 500 right and so
it's a 5 000 swing off of a you know 25
000 nut for them and one of them might
take them three months and one of them
might take them a day so what is their
incentive
their incentive is to get the is to is
to make as much money as possible per
unit of time and so they're incentivized
to sell as fast as possible and so this
is one of those things where you have to
put your thinking cap on and say are our
incentives truly aligned and so when
we're looking at this when I say there's
two aspects that I look for Council or
somebody who's going to help me do
something financially legally Insurance
wise whatever it is so first is that
Integrity piece and are there incentives
aligned the incentives being aligned and
you could restructure that deal and say
hey you know what you're going to get
zero percent on anything below four
hundred thousand dollars I'll give you
three percent on anything between 400
and 450 and then from 450 and up I'll
give you 20 right or 15 or whatever
right and so now they're highly
incentivized to push and now your
incentives are aligned because each
increment for you is worth almost as
much it is to them and that is how you
would align incentives all right now how
do you test for the second thing which
is their skill set
this one's hard all right especially if
you don't have the perspective from
which to make a judgment which when I
enter new things when I'm trying to
learn about trust and I'm trying to
learn about investment things and
different Vehicles I'm learning about
storage units more about multi like
you're like oh man there's so much stuff
and there's so much Nuance that you have
to have right and so the first thing is
I like to usually read two to three
books on the topic all right and I read
two to three books just so I don't
appear like an idiot
um and so I can at least understand what
they're saying and they're going to
respect you to they will it's kind of
like defense if you bring your if you
bring at least some level of knowledge
they don't feel like they're going to
take advantage of you so this is this is
the first thing that I do and this is
because I don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action I said in the
first hand which is try and talk as to
as many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
Consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that that
buys X Y and Z right or you'd or you
have somebody who who manages your
portfolio whatever it is right that one
decision can be one of the most if not
the biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do I think this
person is Integris do I think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because I don't
want my mom doing my Investments I know
she has my best at heart but she has no
idea what she's doing and then I don't
want somebody who absolutely knows what
they're doing and does not have my best
interest at heart right which honestly
unfortunately is a lot more of the cases
that that you'll come up with and
candidly you know a lot of times they're
literally incentivized against you you
know uh in the insurance industry
they're they're kind of incentivized to
rip you off it's it's it's pretty
terrible and there's a lot of Industries
like that mortgage brokers are
incentivized to rip you off and so you
really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth and your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with
when I started in this business I took
every single sale and it was because I
was so afraid that somebody would waste
the opportunity so if you have that fear
I understand where you're coming from
second when I had my first sale that was
not me I I just had this emotional
breakdown because I was like oh my God
this could actually happen and I promise
you if you haven't had it happen yet you
will when it does because you realize
that this business can actually work
without you and other people can make it
rain too right and then I'll tell you a
quick story that that illustrate the
next point that would make so as I you
know hired some sales people now that
first sales person were they accept or
don't know but they were able to get the
job done later on I had my first kind of
like killer
um and his name was Mario negretti and
he uh he came in
I don't know a year or two into the
business a year into the business and he
so quickly was able to assume the sales
role and to show you how laughable this
is he started and I was about to start
training him and some lady walked in the
door and I was like hey man like I can
take he's like no I'm good he's like go
do your thing he's like Fitness
Nutrition accountability okay I'll
figure it out and he ended up closing
this first lady who walked in the door
for paid in full and I remember walking
in like completely dumbstruck I was like
he didn't even know what the pitch was
but she walked out giggling happy so
excited to start and with that moment
taught me was that
it is good to train sales people but
it's better to take great sales people
and then just point them in a direction
and so this has informed a lot of the
thinking that I have Around Talent in
general and I'll tell you a couple of
Frameworks that have informed this but
like if you look at Harvard Harvard
doesn't produce the smartest people they
select the smartest people and then they
put smart uh professors in front of them
but like the base level of intelligence
of everyone who's at Harvard is already
exceptionally high and so like even if
the teachers at Harvard were not
exceptional the students are and they
would be successful independent of that
because their selection is so ridiculous
right and so if we can think about our
own companies that way and especially if
you're in the service business like look
at the biggest service companies out
there like look at McKinsey look at Bain
look at BCG look at basically a lot of
the finance world is or service-based
businesses a lot of times right and
they're able to do that because they
create such a pool to select from that
they are able to skim for the best
talent right I heard this uh quote from
uh es true Kathy who's the founder of
Chick-fil-A you win the championship in
the draft and so it was such a belief
that they had about picking the right
people even more so than training and I
would say that I have moved in that
direction of a little bit more nature
than nurture when it comes to roles
specifically sales especially there are
certain characteristics about building
Rapport about having certain you know
Dynamics or energy whatever you want to
say that like Mario negrady when he
walked in he had all of these things and
he didn't even know the pitch but he won
that sale off of Just Pure Rapport and
so if I'm going to allocate the same
level of time to training somebody I
might as well start with somebody who
has a much higher base because I could
spend 10 hours to take someone from a
two to a four and a half or I could
spend the same 10 hours taking someone
from a six to a nine and the thing is
I'm also going to get more bang for my
buck in terms of my hours of training
with somebody who has natched a natural
somebody for selling compared to
somebody who does not what's interesting
about this and this is just like my
observation is that you just have to be
willing to talk to more people in the
recruiting process I will say like from
a recruiting standpoint there's there's
two kind of things to look out for if
you're if you're if you cannot pay super
handsomely based on your price points
which you need to maybe fix later but
like if you can't pay super well for the
sales person then you need to look
harder and you'll need to interview more
people and you'll need to probably run
ads and use your network if you can pay
well the best sales people are already
employed and so it comes down to
recruiting those sales people from other
sales jobs ideally from companies just
like yours so that they already know a
lot of the things coming into it so it
decreases the ramp up time for them
because all we were really doing is
swapping products and the actual sales
cycle the type of sale is it a
transactional sales at a long sales at a
software sales is it a coaching program
set whatever it is right there's so few
variables that were changing that they
can immediately Jump and Go which also
allows you to make a judgment on their
proficient you faster and so as a quick
side note to this because this is
something that I've given a lot of
thought if you look at the top sales
people and sales trainers and this is
going to drive Point Drive home the
point that I was making earlier about it
being much of it being born all right is
that if you look at the top people who
are in the space you look at Jordan
Belfort right you look at Bradley you
look at and some people would would say
me in term from a selling perspective
all the guys that I know who have taught
sales were exceptional sales people day
one Bradley started selling cars when he
was 18 years old was the top salesman at
18 years old when he started and he was
like I just found something I was really
good at Jordan Belfort talks about how
he didn't know how to train anybody in
his book and then all of a sudden he for
the first time ever wrote out a
framework to explain the straight line
sale system which became his book and
all that kind of stuff but he up to that
point it was just what he naturally did
right and I can tell you in my instance
as well I'd already closed thousands of
deals before I even consumed my first
sales training and so like I I do think
that if we are selecting sales people I
think it's much more about selection
than it is about training the training
is to remind them how good they are not
necessarily to make them good all right
and this is something that has shifted
over time for me specifically now if
you're like well I suck at sales you can
absolutely put way more time into
yourself than a business would recently
put into an employee all right like you
have you all the time so you can train
you in all your off hours and you're
spending your own time to invest in
yourself but from a return on investment
perspective it's the cost of finding a
good salesperson compared to the cost of
training a bad or mediocre sales person
is significantly lower it's much easier
to find the right people than it is to
take somebody and then make such a crazy
extensive training unless your entire
model is we just take on every single
person who walks in the door like 24
Hour Fitness has this model they take on
anybody who has a pulse and then they
put them through a ridiculous culling
process and then 10 of people make it in
the first 90 days a lot of people I
would say mistakenly think that the
number one resource is time
right everyone's like time is money time
is money time is money
and I would argue that that's not
necessarily true I would argue that
attention is money that is the golden
resource so the billionaire friend that
I have he's actually uh been helping me
on um the new Endeavor that we are
launching to our gym Lords uh soon which
I think will change the industry anyways
he's been helping me with that stuff but
like here's an example on his phone his
phone does not ring unless you are
already a contact that has been
whitelisted his phone doesn't ring it's
he's impossible to reach the more
successful the more the the larger your
company grows the more you scale the
more you need to scale and really to
scale you is because you do have a
finite amount of attention and so what
happens is you have to decrease all of
the other things in your life that drain
attention because you can have as much
time as you want but if you're not there
you're not potent you're not able then
you can't get anything done with that
time that you're supposedly allocating
which is why a lot of people end up in
this in between state of always
everywhere and at the same time nowhere
right and so they're they're everywhere
but they're not paying attention to
anything and that's and the reason that
it's difficult to focus is because
entrepreneurs the character trait that
made us into entrepreneurs is that we're
go-getters we're we're risk averse we're
creators we're innovators we're Builders
right we have all of those traits but
the difficulty is is that the thing that
gets you from zero to one is not the
thing that gets you from one to two
right and so one of the the reason that
you have to totally morph and why you
have to be a growth oriented individual
is because you have to change your own
individual character traits in order to
progress as a business owner and so like
I said the things that got you here are
not the things that are going to get you
there the things that got you here which
is your own internal skills are not the
things that you need to pass on to other
people so the only way that you were
able to grow your business at a certain
point is by growing other people right
and the only way you can do that is if
you have the attention and the bandwidth
in order to do so and that's why if you
look at a business owner and like the
more I obsess on looking at billionaires
and people who are doing better than we
are is I look at how quiet and how clean
they keep their space and I mean that
both in a literal sense that like their
surroundings their office their house
their homes their cell phone their
computers right there it's it's it's
quiet right everything like it's it's
pristine and when you talk to these
people there's a certain amount of of
Tranquility that's there and
and they just they just have very low
tolerance and it's not that they're
trying to be impatient with you or I'm
patient with the world it's just that
they understand that they have so like
they're they're operating at such a high
level that there's so many things that
are demanding of their time and
attention that they just like they can't
and so they have to forcibly remove
themselves from so many different
situations and I'm going to give you an
example so one of the people that I'm
I'm someone mentoring right they had
they had four businesses and this is
something that happens so many times it
lit like like you want you want a
hundred thousand dollar coaching this is
what happens in hundred thousand dollar
coaching sessions and I'm being honest
with you what happens is someone who's
coming in usually doing between one and
three million dollars a year
um can't get past a certain point right
and the reason they can't get past is
because they only have so much attention
and if it's spread between four or five
different kids that's when the gym owner
has four gyms and is making less money
than they did when they had one gym
because the amount of attention that
they can allocate to one facility has
gone down so much that with fixed costs
they basically you're breaking even
right and so the same thing happens now
that entrepreneur is probably making one
to three million in gross revenue but
not taking anything home because they
don't have the intention to actually put
onto things and so in order to grow you
need to do less
in order to grow you need to do less and
that comes from both delegation and also
choosing what not to do the better you
get the better the opportunities that
you have to say no to imagine the level
of opportunities that we have now I'm
just being honest so imagine how many
things we could do or trying JV with or
do a partnership with or whatever
because of the distribution Network that
we have and the trust and the Goodwill
that we have with the gym owners that we
have in our Network right a lot I get I
you know how many people cold message me
like I have an opportunity for you I'm
like really you have an opportunity for
me and so the better you get the better
your opportunities you have to say no to
which is why becoming a higher and
higher and higher level entrepreneur is
more and more difficult because it
requires discipline
it's not about doing more it's about
doing less because we innately want to
do more so doing more of your own
internal characteristic if that was what
it took to get to be more successful
then everyone would be more successful
because it would be something that does
not take effort because that is
something that we already do it's like
man I outwork anyone I've got all this
work ethic cool that gets you from zero
to one
it's not going to get you any further
than that so stop identifying with that
it was something that I used to identify
with I was like I'll I'll outwork anyone
or whatever like that was something that
I used to think about and it was a
character trade it was an identity thing
and the more you grow the more you
realize that your identity needs to be
fluid because what it needs to be is
exactly what it needs to be at that
given time of development because the
character traits that I'm going to have
to emphasize in a year are going to be
different than the ones that I have to
emphasize now the skills that you need
to learn like delegation leadership
those are things that are not the things
that take you in the beginning you have
to be independent you have to be
hustling you have to be grinding you
have to be willing to put in the work
because no one else will do it for you
especially if you have no Capital to
start which most people who are on here
are in that situation to reel this back
in the number one thing that you have to
be paying attention to is where you are
paying your attention
right like you spend attention that's
why they call it paying attention it's
because it is a resource and most people
don't pay attention to that right and so
one of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me this one's going to
go along
um a lot of some of the things that a
lot of people don't know about me is
that I for nine months paid a coach to
teach me one thing which was to manage
my attention
was to teach me how to think and so for
90 minutes every single day all I did
was talk about what I was thinking about
think about that
every day I paid attention to where my
attention was
and when I did that all of a sudden my
business blew up right and I realized
that I had toxic relationships I had
toxic relationships with parents I had
toxic relationships with friends or
pseudo friends things that I that were
taking my attention past things that I
had on my mind that I knew I had not
handled so those are called like open
Loops or open Cycles right so when you
have something that you like I haven't
resolved this then you need to handle
that and you'll get that attention back
because what happens is you have this
bowl this tiny little bowl of marbles
that each of those marbles is is a unit
of attention right if you had to measure
it and so you put little marbles of
attention on your childhood promise you
put little marbles of attention on your
marriage you put little uh marbles of
attention on your health you put little
marbles of attention on your
spirituality and then massive marbles of
attention on your business but the thing
is is that sometimes you need to quiet
and collect all of these other little
marbles so that you have more potency
more potential energy more potential
units of attention to spend on the one
thing that you're trying to grow which
in this case would be your business and
what's interesting is that what happens
is that things that were perceived as
difficult become really easy and I don't
know if you've ever had this happen but
like if you were in college or you were
in high school and you were like man I
can't solve this problem this math
problem and you were exhausted and you
go to bed and you wake up the next
morning and then all of a sudden it
seems really easy or you're like I don't
know why I didn't see that before
because attention gives you the ability
to see
right like if you're if you think about
wisdom right wisdom is an ability to see
what other people cannot see right two
people are presented the same situation
the wiser person sees things that the
other person does it and how can you see
better you see better if you have more
ability to see which comes from your
most valuable resource attention how
much horsepower do you have and so look
at the things that you have in your in
your life right now like if I see
someone who has a messy relationship
life who's got a messy love life who
goes out every weekend and gets trashed
right like I can tell you billionaires
don't do that that like the whole Tony
Stark like vision of the entrepreneur is
a farce it's not true don't believe that
every single billionaire every single
high-level entrepreneur is quiet
unbelievably quiet they keep themselves
completely isolated they have a bubble
around them of of layers of protection
they're like like for me it's it's me
and then there's Layla and then we have
our CEO and then we have our executive
assistant team because we have a team of
EAS at this point we have four
um who work the next level there's no
one who has direct access to me
including our employees no one does and
that's because it's it would disserve
you you guys our gym owners if everyone
had access to me the reason that I don't
respond to Facebook messages is not
because I don't want to it's because I
literally can't and if I did I would be
disturbing everyone because then my
attention would be split because someone
can't generate leads in their mind or
whatever you know what I mean like
because these little things these little
things that are perceived as huge issues
to you in that moment because you have a
little bit of attention you you have so
little left that everything seems like
an explosion but when you have lots of
capacity City big problem seems small
and small problems seem big and it
sounds reverse because what you do is
you start seeing that all of these
things are attention drains and you just
say I don't want to play anymore
and you stop playing
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the last one on one I did
with Gary vaynerchuk check check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I'm talking about
something that the world thinks is a
contradiction I don't understand why
anybody should ever verbally dress down
an employee